que pensent donc les Français de la très
prochaine réforme monétaire oh il y aura
beaucoup moins d'argent dans les poches
c'est tout à une pièce de la Franc 100
franc si je comprends bien qu' y a
beaucoup qui vont s'y perdre oh ben on
s'y habituera au début sera peut-être un
peu gênant et bien ila un petit calcul à
faire oh il va y avoir sûrement beaucoup
de bêtises faites au début on divisera
par 10 non ça fait pas de différence il
suffit de savoir un tout petit peu
calculer quoi prenons un exemple vous
payez ce journal 25 franc combien le
pirez-vous un nouveau franc euh
25 centimes 2 fran50 25
centimes euh 2 Fran 50 s 025 quel
avantage qu'il puisse y avoir je me le
demande si la vie reste sur le train m
c'est pareil pour moi j'espère que ça
donnera une confiance nouvelle au
français on divisera les salaires par
100 on divisera les pris par 100 je vois
pas quel sera l'avantage je m'en fout du
franc lourd moi